Oggcast U-Vo Guten Tag, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu der neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO.
Völlig richtig und natürlich, wie es sich gehört, das muss sein, ohne geht doch irgendwie nicht.
Stefan Tietze, danke schön, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid, denn auch ihr dürft nicht fehlen.
Von wem war denn dieses, wie ich finde, perfekt lange Intro?
Ja, dieses Intro, das ein bisschen zu lang war, kam von Sir Sonntag, der man den Sonntag quasi für sich beansprucht hat.
Die Analyse Perfekt lange Intro. Ja, dieses Intro, das ein bisschen zu lang war, kam von Sir Sonntag, der man den Sonntag quasi für sich beansprucht hat.
Die anderen Wochentage sind noch zu verfügbar. Montag, Dienstag, Stefan, Donnerstag, Freitag, Samstag, Sonntag. Man sagt ja, wenn man irgendwann mal ablebt, was sagen die Leute über einen, und dann glaube ich, würde man über dich sagen, ja, Stefan war so ein Mensch wie der Donnerstag. Das ist so eine Grabrede von jemandem, dem man nichts abgewinnen kann. Ja. Wir sind jetzt zusammengekommen, um diesen besonderen Menschen zu ehren. Er war wie so ein bedeckter Donnerstag. Wenn man sich für einen Monat entscheiden würde, würde man wahrscheinlich sagen, es war ein Oktober. Herbert war ein Oktober. Wenn ein Auto war, sind sich alle einig, Nissan. Herbert war wie die Schlüsselschale, die im Flur steht, schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren.
Da sind mittlerweile viele Krümel drin.
Niemand weiss so recht woher, man legt da doch immer nur den Schlüssel rein.
Aber im Laufe der Zeit haben sich dann doch einige Krümel dort gefunden, und das war Herbert.
Wenn man sich so einen Kühlschrank anschaut, wir alle haben es, wir alle brauchen es.
Unten hat man das Fach, wo man Fleisch reinmacht oder Gemüse, Selleriestangen. Ganz oben Bierflaschen oder so Mandelmilch. Herbert war keins dieser beiden Fächer. Herbert ist nicht so einfach einzuordnen, Herbert war das mittlere Fach. Nicht erst auf Augenhöhe, ist leicht drunter. Man kann einfach Dinge reinlegen oder rausnehmen. Man kann es befüllen oder leerlassen. Amen. Ganz ehrlich. Stefan Tietze hatte stets etwas, Stefan Tietze ist wie dieses eine Stück, was man zwischen den Zähnen hat und was man einfach nicht rauskriegt. Und irgendwann ist man so dran gewohnt, dass man gar nicht merken würde, wenn es weg wäre, weil man sich so dran gewöhnt hat. Wenn Pfarrer so wären, weil ich denke mir ja, die müssen ja irgendwann, ich habe mir immer, wenn diese, ich weiß nicht, wie es dir ging, aber als ich damals in der Kirche war, gezwungen wurde, reinzugehen, Bei der Pfarrerpredigt habe ich immer mir vorgestellt, wie er die am Vorabend schreibt,
noch so gestresst, wie ich so ein Essay oder so einen Aufsatz noch schreiben muss.
Aber es ist eher so ein durch den Raum wandeln und man hat irgendwie so einen Lautsprecher, so, ähm, Jesus ist wie ein Fels, äh, streichen, streichen, alles streichen, alles streichen,
löschen, Jesus ist wie ein Fels, äh, streichen, streichen, alles streichen, alles streichen, alles streichen, löschen. Jesus ist wie ein Adventskalender, wo man nach einer stressigen Woche merkt, oh, ich hab noch drei Türen, streichen, alles löschen, alles löschen, alles löschen, ich kann nichts, ich kann gar nichts, fick dich, fick dich. Hölle, Hölle für mich, Hölle für mich, Hölle für mich, alles löschen. So stellt man sich das ein bisschen vor. Ja, ich hab mir vorgestellt, wie die dann so … Oder an der Schreibmaschine. Ja, an der Schreibmaschine, in einem halbdunklen Zimmer und dann so … und das Blatt so wegwerfen und auf so einem Berg, wo andere zusammengeknüllte Papiere schon liegen. Und ich habe mir gerade gedacht, was, wenn die, ähnlich wie so Podcaster, einfach so eigene Geschichten erzählen, so was ihnen gerade passiert ist, weil er hat es vergessen, er hat nichts. Und dann merkt er, ah fuck, in Punkt drei der Setlist ist Predigt, ich habe nichts. Ich habe gar nichts. Und dann geht er davon hin, was ich jetzt, wie ich jetzt sagen würde, als Podcaster würde ich jetzt sagen, ich war gestern bei der Zahnreinigung, erst Kontrolle und dann die Reinigung, manchmal auch umgekehrt. Und dann bin ich da hingegangen und die nette Dame hat mir meinen gesamten Mundraum gereinigt. Der ganze Dreck ist weg, Plack ist ab. Und jetzt kann ich wieder über der Zunge jeden Ort befühlen und man denkt, was ist der Sinn der Predigt, aber er hat nichts. Hey, wo kommen jetzt Christentum noch? Er erzählt einfach nur, was privat passiert ist. So die ganzen Nerds, ah, das wird die Remias wieder, das wird irgendwie Jakob. Es geht nur darum, wie du es präsentierst. Ja, ist auch eine gute Reihe, so Leute, die eigentlich einen Podcast haben sollten, einfach Leute, die voll labern, auch an der Kasse oder so, und denkst einfach, die Technik ist mittlerweile wirklich erschwinglich. Du kriegst für 80 Cent, kriegst du wirklich das meiste, was du brauchst und kannst dann einfach losstarten. Und jetzt kommt meine Zunge wieder an die kleinen Zwischenräume. Suchend. Und Florentin, lass dir gesagt sein, ich war froh, dass meine Zunge oder der Dreck das Brötchen, was ich gerade aas, was es uns Jesus gab, war eigentlich nie. Die ganze Gemeinde, ahhh. Er ist gut, er ist gut, er ist verdammt gut. Das kann jetzt an die Zwischenräume, die vorher besetzt waren, von bereits Dreck, und meine Zunge hatte sich daran gewöhnt. Nun aber steckt es drin. Ich merke genau, bei der Zahnreinigung sind jetzt wieder Löcher entstanden, Zwischenräume entstanden, wo sich neuer Dreck absetzen kann. Also er meint, wenn man beicht und seine Sünden auswäscht, können dann neue, grössere Sünden in die entstehenden Wuhelräume? Oder wie?
Er wird es bestimmt gleich erklären.
Ich will es auf die ganze Folge Sinn machen.
Letztens war ich im ICE.
Der Ruheabend.
Aber kannst du, hast du eine Täterliste?
Also hast du noch mal in dem Kopf
die Täterliste aufgeschrieben, wer
könnte es gewesen sein, was hast du gegessen?
Ja, gerade das Brötchen.
Der vegane Bagel. Na, aber da gibt es nichts. Bei Brötchen, da löst sich ja alles auf. Du brauchst ja irgendwas Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, was hast du gegessen, was könnte dazwischen, aber Brötchen, der vegane Bagel, na aber da gibt es nichts, bei Brötchen, da löst sich ja alles auf, du brauchst ja irgendwas, Moment mal, normalerweise hat man ja sowas bei Fleisch eigentlich, wenn da so Sehniges oder so dazwischen hängt, gerade irgendwie so diese Serrano-Schinken oder so, vielleicht war dein veganes Sandwich gar nicht wirklich vegan. Das ist so nervig, weil jetzt habe ich das zwischen den Zähnen. Aber genau da, weil ich habe hinten einen Retainer. Ich hatte früher eine Zahnspange.
Ich glaube, wir alle einen Retainer.
Ich hatte früher eine Zahnspange.
Ich glaube, wir alle haben Retainer. Jeder Mensch,
das hatten wir bereits, jeder Mensch
hat einen Retainer. Jedes Mal, wenn man
zum Zungenkuss ansetzt, merkt man,
ich hänge fest, Hilfe, ich hänge
fest. Und ist es mir leid,
ich werde die ganze Folge versuchen,
diesen Krümel rauszubekommen.
Soll ich dich küssen? Er ist vorne zwischen den... Was? Ne, soll ich dich küssen, um den... Warum sagst du das ständig, fragst du diese Frage? Ich habe immer das Gefühl, das... Er ist einfach ganz pragmatisch, um rauszusaugen, um dieses Stück mal von der anderen Seite auch rauszusaugen. Ich kann ja selber den Unterdruck von oben erstellen. Du kannst... Aber in welche Richtung geht der Unterdruck? Ich könnte in die andere Richtung Unterdruck.
Boah, es ist so unangenehm, aber ey, dafür sind meine Zähne wieder wunderschön sauber, aber gerade beim Retainer hinten, ihr werdet es kennen, alle die nach 1990 geboren sind, glaube ich, haben einen Retainer. Jeder hat einen Retainer. Und das fühlt sich ja total geil an, wenn da dann irgendwann dieser Zahnstein drüber ist.
Weil dann ist die Zunge so, alles ist so schön glatt.
Aber wenn das gereinigt wird, bin ich der Einzige?
Hasse ich das! Und dann geht das in diesen Ort und alles ist spitz und eklig und scharf und schneidet die Zunge auf. Und da ist es so Platz für so Dreck, so Brotdreck. Das ist wieder der Unrelatable Comedian. Ja! Mir geht das nicht auch, wenn du richtig Zahnsteine hast und es so richtig und es kam zum Publikum wie choreografiert, schüttelt den Kopf einfach. Nein, nein. Mir sagt der Arzt, alle haben Zahnsteine da im Retailer. Aber ich glaube, mein Retailer verrutscht immer so ein Stückchen und ich kriege es nicht mit und im Laufe der Zeit rutscht er noch einmal rüber und ich habe Angst, dass ich irgendwann dann mit wieder krummen Zähnen aufwache und dann komplett wieder von vorne anfange. Wem kommt der vorne dann so an? Ich habe ja tatsächlich Zahnspange gehabt und dann kriegt man ja so eine Plastikspange, die man
dann immer noch tragen muss, nachts,
und dann wirst du so als
Pubertierender entlassen und dann
irgendwann, zehn Jahre später
trägst du es immer noch und denkst,
wann, also mir wurde nie gesagt,
bis wann, so, normalerweise kriegst du ein Medikament,
genau, normalerweise kriegst du ein Medikament,
da sind halt zehn Stück drin.
Da denkst du, okay, ich nehme zehn Stück dann das aus.
Aber da, und jetzt ist der mittlerweile gebrochen.
Die Oberseite ist gebrochen von dieser Plastikspange, die man immer nachts einst.
Du machst sie immer noch rein.
Und ich mache sie immer noch rein. Beide Teile.
Weil ich mir denke, besser als nichts.
Aber wahrscheinlich schlagen sich jetzt gerade alle Givautenpäden.
Ich würde sagen, der ist auch schlechter als nichts.
Ja, das kann auch sein, weil der natürlich unter enormem Druck steht. Besser als nichts ist kein guter Spruch. Der muss ja was, ja gut, aber besser als einfach die Natur, ihre Kräfte stürmen. Bei den meisten ist nichts besser als was. Ja, ja. Was ist besser als, ja. Was. Ja, ja. Manchmal ist nichts besser als was. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Aber das klingt nicht so gut, man soll das interagieren, nichts ist besser als was. Ja. Soll ich mal so ein bisschen sauber machen? Nichts ist besser als was. Nichts ist besser als was. Das klingt wie ein Satz, den man nicht vollständig ausgesprochen hat. Es klingt aber auch ein bisschen so wie so ein Roman, der dann zu einem sehr erfolgreichen Til-Schweiger-Film wird. So, nichts ist besser als was. Es war eigentlich mal ein wirklich seriöser, ernsthafter Roman, der wirklich ins Innere gegangen ist, dann aber verhudelt wurde. Der Autor natürlich in Geldnot musste das Skript verkaufen irgendwie für läppische 12.000 Euro. Und Til Schweiger macht dann so eine läppische Komödie draus und das ganze Leben lang wird der Autor angesprochen, sie sind doch Christian Habelmann, sie haben doch nichts ist besser als was geschrieben. Ich fand den so klasse, wie der der Nackt dasteht und dann hat der diesen hat der diesen Drink getrunken. Der Film hat nichts mit meinem Buch zu tun. So, aber ich mochte die Szene so gerne. Der Film hat nichts und dann packe ich dich so an den Schultern und du bist mit deinem Kleinkind da. Und du packst auch das Kind. Ja, das Kind packe ich auch. Schüttel das Kind. Zufangen an zu schreien. Du bist mittlerweile sehr gut darin, Leute zu schütteln einfach. Ja. Aber Till Schweiger hat zu viel getrunken, dann war er am Set, hat Leute beschimpft. Ich glaube, Gewalt war auch im Spiel, lehnt mich jetzt aber nicht aufs Fenster, deswegen sage ich das lieber nicht. Schweiger, du machst jetzt Schweiger. Ich schweige. Und deswegen ist er jetzt, glaube ich, raus aus dem Business. Oh, das weiss ich gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Ich bin da nicht aktuell mit dabei. Aber hast du das Gefühl gerade, dass sehr viel so Drama herrscht? Ja, ich, aber ich. Und ich finde das irgendwie auch, also ganz ehrlich, ich weiss, das ist keine Popular Op popular opinion, aber ich finde es immer ein bisschen spannend auch. Ja klar, darum geht es ja. Das ist ja Content, das ist ja auch schön lästern. Aber ich bin da nicht so richtig drin. Ich auch nicht so richtig. Ich bin nicht so richtig drin, ich schaue gerade Matrix 4, ich versuche gerade Matrix 4 zu verstehen, das ist mein Thema. Videos an, zu Dingen, wo ich weder den, der das Statement macht, kenne, ich kenne auch nicht den, über den er spricht, ich weiss nicht, wer wer ist, ich weiss nicht immer, ob es YouTuber, TikToker, Regisseure oder Comedian sind. Ja, ich kriege immer nur so die Statements und Reaktionen auf den Urtext mit, aber den Urtext selber, den fasst man nicht. Das ist so ein bisschen wie, dann muss man das archäologisch wieder ausgraben, worum ging es denn ursprünglich? Und das Arbeit, das ist kein Spaß. Mag ich keine Arbeit, Arbeit nicht. Nein, nein, nein, nein, will ich nicht. Nein, danke schön, will ich nicht, auf gar keinen Fall. Aber eher ist es spannend, ich verfolge das auch so ein bisschen, natürlich, man will mitreden, man will lästern können, aber ich, auf der anderen Seite bin ich, wie gesagt, auch gerade Matrix 4 dran, einfach, ne, das ist einfach für mich gerade Themen. Moment, aber hilf mir kurz auf die Sprünge und allen anderen auch. Matrix 4 war der letzte Matrix mit Neil Patrick Harris. Ja, und der Film ist so fucking strange einfach. Der ist so, so strange, weil der ist so selbstreferentiell. Wo Szenen aus Matrix laufen. Genau, du siehst in Matrix 4, siehst du Szenen aus Matrix 1 bis 3, weil Neo als Thomas Anderson hat in der Welt die Mat... Als Paul Thomas Anderson dreht Buggy Nights in Matrix 3. Aber als Videospiel. In der Welt von Matrix gibt es in der Matrix die Matrix-Filme als Videospiel. Ja. Und Thomas Anderson, also der bürgerliche Name von Neo, ist der Programmierer dieser Spiele. Und die Agenten zeigen, also die Protagonisten zeigen ihm sein Videospiel, um ihm zu sagen, guck mal, das ist echt. Das ist alles wirklich passiert. Und er sagt, nee, das habe ich ja selber gemacht. Es ist ein Spiel. Es ist ein Spiel und es ist so fucking verwirrend einfach. Und allein die Tatsache, in einem vierten Teil Ausschnitte aus den ersten drei zu zeigen. Ich will nicht so viel verraten, weil er gerade noch im Kino läuft, aber ich war in Furiosa, dem neuen Mad Max-Film. Und ich glaube, ich verrate nicht so viel, weil im Abspann läuft der erste Film. Geil, ichzenen aus dem ersten Film, also dem letzten Fury Road, sind in Furiosa. Also der Abspann, die Credits sind unterschnitten mit Teil 1. Geil, warum nicht? Warum nicht? Na ja, ich finde nicht, warum nicht? Ein Film ist wie ein Überraschungsei, du kriegst mehr als du dachtest, dass du kriegst. Du kriegst am Ende, hier, komm mal, Need for Speed 3, komm mal der ganze Abspann, hier einfach nochmal komplett, bleibt sitzen und ihr schaut Need for Speed 3. Nee, weil der Abspann ist Free Solo. Ja, genau, genau. Der Abspann ist eine Dokumentation, ist eine andere Dokumentation. Sind wir ehrlich, Filmmacher sind nicht mehr diese Alfred Hitchcock-Gentlemen-Leute der alten Zeit. Filmemacher heutzutage sind Lachsverkäufer auf dem Hamburger Fischmarkt. Komm, ich hau dir doch die Lachsseite oben drauf. Komm, du kriegst noch Mad Max, Mad Max, man will Fury rollt, kriegst du oben drauf. Kriegst du drauf. Im Abspann hast du noch mal das neue Teil des Swift-Album, hörst du einfach mal oben drauf, kriegst du einfach für keinen Preis oben drauf.
Dankeschön. Einfach mal oben drauf. Und dann gehst du raus und merkst, ich habe trotzdem acht Euro für ein Fischbrüchen gezahlt. Richtig, ja. Aber du musst natürlich so ein bisschen um die Aufmerksamkeit halt kämpfen. Und Matrix 4, ich habe ja noch nicht gecheckt, aber es ist unglaublich, weil er so selbstreferentiell ist, weil dann soll Neo den vierten Teil programmieren. Und dann sagt der Chef so, ja, du musst den vierten Teil bringen Und dann sagt Neo, nee, das will ich nicht. Dann sagt er, ja gut, wenn du es nicht machst, machen wir es. Und das ist exakt, was passiert ist mit Warner Brothers und Lana Barkowski. Ah ja, genau. Keinen weiteren machen wollte. Und dann hieß es, dann machen wir einen ohne euch. Dann musst du trotzdem machen. Das ist so fucking selbstreferenziell. Und dann sagen die, ja, was macht Matrix aus? Na ja, so Mindfuck-Momente, brainstormen die, den Film, den wir gerade sehen. Das ist unfassbar. Es erinnert mich an den letzten Gute-Arbeit-Sketch, wo wir auch die Geschichte reinbauen wollten ein bisschen. Auch selbstreferentiell und ironischerweise auch eine Matrix-Referenz. Ja, absolut. Na klar, am Ende ist es immer Matrix. Aber das ist so, vor allem, Matrix 1 bis 3 war ja null selbstreferenziell und dann einfach auf hundert gedreht. Es gibt ja manche Franchise, die sind so, Scream, ja, oder Arrested Development, wo man so einen Ton hat, wo die vierte Wand bröckelt. Aber bei Matrix nix. Und ich stelle mir einfach so vor, wie irgendwie Herr der Ringe, ganz am Ende schreibt ja Frodo there and back again, schreibt ja die Geschichte auf. Und wenn dann so Pippin reinkäme und sagt, Mensch, ist aber relativ viel Laufen in deinem Buch, oder? Viel Landschaftsbeschreibung in deinem Buch, oder? Und der komische Sidekick von Frodo hättest du auch rausschreiben können. Und dann gucken alle in die Kamera. Und dann ist sie so, oh, was ist das? Mit hochgezogenen Schultern. Ich weiß nicht. Ich weiß es nicht. Es kommt so aus wie nichts und es ist absolut fantastisch. Aber ich will diesen Film wirklich wie die Bibel studieren. Du willst ihn verstehen. Ich will ihn einmal verstanden haben, weil ich will wissen, ob der eine innere Logik hat oder ob es einfach nur Quatsch ist. Das Ding ist ja, manchmal hat man so Werke, die man nicht versteht, aber die haben so den Test der Zeit bestanden.anden genug intellektuelle haben es durchdrungen und man weiss was ich da schaue oder lese geht man
kann es durchdringen ja man kann es verstehen und sich aneignen bei matrix vier bin ich mir nicht
sicher ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher ob das überhaupt durchdringbar ist oder ob quasi der
das ziel schon die verwirrung ist Vor allem ist es ja, der Film ist ja
aufgebaut, dass er am Anfang bewusst
verwirrend ist. Also das gibt es ja
manchmal, dass Filme beginnen mit,
hä, warum hat der gerade nicht gemerkt,
dass das, was passiert ist, der läuft an einem
Autounfall vorbei und schaut gar
nicht hin, hä, ist ja komisch.
Und dann merkt man, ah, okay, der ist blind
oder was auch immer, so, und dann wird es aufgeklärt.
Genau. Und in dem Film wird diese
Verwirrung einfach nie aufgeklärt.
Es ist einfach durchgehend
Vielen Dank. merkt man, ah, okay, der ist blind oder was auch immer. So, und dann wird das aufgeklärt. Und in dem Film wird diese Verlöpfung einfach nie aufgeklärt.
Es ist einfach durchgehend unklar, was passiert. Blinde laufen die ganze Zeit an Autounfällen vorbei, die checken nichts.
Die Figur ist von Anfang bis Ende blind, aber es wird einfach nie gesagt.
Dann ist es ja, Moment, warum haut er immer dagegen?
In Action-Szenen haut er immer neben die Leute, was ist da los?
Es wird einfach nie aufgeklärt.
Und dann gibt es eine Szene am Anfang, wo er in den Spiegel schaut und sein Spiegelbild sieht anders aus als er. Und cut zur nächsten Szene. Aber dann denkt man auch, bei Mafix ist es so, man kommt gut durch mit sowas. Absolut, absolut. Also man denkt hier so, ja, wahrscheinlich war das dann nicht, es ist so wie Harry Potter, also da kann auch weirder Shit passieren, Aber die Welt ist ja schon so brückelig in ihrer inneren Logik, dass man es ja nicht unbedingt ...
Es ist nicht wie, keine Ah Saving Private Ryan guckst und er sieht ein anderes Spiegelbild, dann würde ich sagen, was? Hä? Ja, aber das finde ich auch mal gut, wenn so ein komplett ernster Film so einen so einen Moment hat, wo man denkt, was ist da los, so Million Dollar Baby und dann irgendwie ist sie im Ring und schaut ins Publikum und sie sitzt selber im Publikum. Und als ganzes Publikum ist es nur sie, wie sie guckt. Hast du gerade geschnipst? Wenn die alle irgendwas machen würden. Wenn die alle so schnippen würden oder alle sowas machen würden und dann geht der Film ganz normal weiter, es wird einfach nie aufgeklärt. Das würde ich machen, wenn ich irgendwie letzter Tag im Schnittraum, so würde ich so eine Sache reinschneiden, so kurz bevor der Film rausgeht, würde ich es nochmal machen und dann einfach geniessen. Ja, finde ich gut. Oder so einen Satz in Buch schreiben. Lektoren haben eine enorme Kraft, weil als ob der Autor sich das Buch nochmal komplett durchlesen würde vor Veröffentlichung.
Der Lektor kann einfach einen Satz in Buch schreiben. Lektoren haben eine enorme Kraft, weil als ob der Autor sich das Buch nochmal komplett durchlesen würde vor Veröffentlichung. Der Lektor kann einfach einen Satz einbauen oder einen Satz auf dem Kopf oder irgendwie so. Völlige Irritation.
Autoren, so richtige Schriftsteller, so Diogenes Verlag und so. Schreiben die ihre Bücher in Word?
Gute Frage.
Schreiben die den in Dark Mode oder im Light Mode? Schreiben die den bei Pages? Schreiben die ihre Bücher in Word? Gute Frage. Schreiben die den in Dark Mode oder im Light Mode? Schreiben die den bei Pages? Schreiben die das in der Schriftart, in der es gedruckt wird, oder ist es egal? So eine ganz kleine Schrift oder eine ganz grosse Schrift? Haben die so ein Buch-Layout oder so was? Ich finde es unterschiedlich, ob ein Wort ganz oben steht oder ganz unten oben steht oder ganz unten steht. Ein Satz kommt, kickt anders geil rein, wenn es auf dem Seitenumbuch. Also zum Beispiel ein Gag zum Beispiel, glaube ich, wo die Feedline ist, der 80% Satz ist und hast für ein Wort, was dann die Punchline ist, wenn es umblättern muss, kickt das anders geil rein. Kickt das anders geil rein, ja. Danke nochmal für dein Zitat von meinem Buchrücken einfach, das hat gut funktioniert.
Das Buch kickt anders geil rein. Das kommt anders geil rein.
Das kommt anders geil rein.
Stefan, 34 Jahre alt.
Das ist das einzige Mal, dass das Alte auch dabei steht.
Das Buch kommt anders geil.
Was natürlich auch unsere Hörer und Hörer schon lange erwarten.
Was?
Wir blättern die nächste Seite um.
Und dann?
Eine unglaublich spannende Geschichte.
Was? Denn du weisst es ja, sind gerade an der sache dran nein also wir haben verschiedene storylines offen zum einen haben wir offen wir wollen leute also zum einen fehlt thais zum anderen fehlt melde dich oh thais wurde entdeckt wir haben ein video bekommen von einem Hörer, einer Hörerin. Ja. Thais war bei Till Reiners angeblich im Hintergrund zu sehen. Der hat so ein Video von seiner Tour hochgeladen. Weiß nicht, ob es in YouTube oder Instagram war. Ist das jetzt Verrat oder wie reagieren wir darauf? Oder drei Lehrer Dominos-Recherche, wir wissen es nicht. Die ist mittlerweile so umfangreich, ihre Dominos-Recherche, kurz zusammengefasst. Wir haben einen Whistleblower, der uns gesagt hat. Whistleblower. Genau, und der hat gesagt, hey, bei Dominos, man kriegt gar nicht das Trinkgeld, was man online dann gibt, bezahlt. Und man kriegt auch keine Salami, wenn man Salami bestellt. Richtig. War meine These dann. Wir haben Thais angesetzt auf die Sache und sie jagt jetzt diesem Auto hinterher.
Oder nicht.
Oder nicht. Sie ist vielleicht so tief in der Recherche, dass sie sich selbst auch nochmal recherchiert.
Oder eben, sie macht nichts, wissen wir nicht. Aber ich finde es schon mal gut, dass sie immer wieder so aufblitzt auf verschiedenen Fotos. Dann gibt es irgendwie so einen Militärputsch in Bangladesch.
Genau. Und dann steht sie da auch so. Aus den 80ern, weirdly. Ist sie da auch schon mittendrin. Ist sie mittendrin. Und deswegen bin ich eigentlich immer guter Dinge. Ich glaube, da kommt noch mal ein Riesending. Sie wird uns einen Tag so ein richtig dickes und folianten Vorsätzen so so. Alles will Claire.
Und wie ich es kenne, werden wir den nicht lesen.
Dann, also das, Thais fehlt immer noch, dann suchen wir immer noch nach Knöllchen, die wir bezahlen können, wenn Leute nämlich wegen uns, weil sie uns gehört haben, abgelenkt waren, gelacht haben, Tränen in den Augen hatten, aufs Gasbiller gedrückt haben, deswegen, oder eine Gießkanne involviert war, wie auch immer. Name fällt uns dann natürlich sofort ein. Michael.
Genau, Michael, die Geschichte fällt uns dann natürlich sofort ein. Michael!
Genau, Michael, die Geschichte mit der Gieskanne. Wurde mittlerweile auch sehr gut verarbeitet, auch zum Beispiel von dem liebgewonnenen Instagram-Account Pufo Memes, wo das auch nochmal aufgerollt wurde, habe ich sehr gelacht. Michael gerat in eine sehr missliche Lage, er war umringt von nervigen Störagenten, auf die Höhe getrieben hat es dann seinen Sohn drei Jahre, der ihm eine Gießkamme vollkommen die Oberseite einer Gießkamme in die Seite gerammt hat, er ist auf der Autobahn ausgewichen, musste beschleunigen, Oma war nicht im Auto. So, was Michael aber gesagt hat, ja, da gab es noch diese Sache mit dem Abschleppen, mit dem Richter, mit dem mehrseitigen Dokument, das er in der Hand hat gegen den Richter. So, da können wir jetzt nicht ins Detail gehen, wir werden sie zum ersten Mal hören, hört da in den letzten Folgen rein. Jetzt war aber noch die Sache mit dieser Autobahn-Giesskannen-Geschichte, dass Michael gesagt hat, ich wurde da geblitzt, aber ich habe noch keine Post. Bislang kam noch nichts. Deswegen für uns aktuell nicht die Möglichkeit, das Scheckbuch in die Hand zu nehmen und diesen armen Mann von seiner finanziellen Last zu erlösen. Jetzt allerdings erreichte mich eine E-Mail. Nein, yes. Neun Uhr vierzig. Oh, ich erreichte eine Mail. Hey, ganz ehrlich, wenn man Mails vorliest, ich finde die Uhrzeit nicht uninteressant. Super wichtig, ja, sehr, sehr wichtig. Deswegen meine ich, manchmal, deswegen will ich ja wissen, wo mein Satz steht, wenn ich ein Buch schreibe. Genau, ich habe auch oft die Situation, dass irgendwie Slack oder so Arbeit, schreibt jemand, ey, kannst du am Donnerstag da und da zu der Uhrzeit hinkommen? Und dann bin ich halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, mal um drei uhr vierzig nachts wach und ich denke mir kann ich jetzt einfach schreibe ich jetzt einfach schreiben ganz im ernst nein und das wollte ich noch sagen du schreibst nervige nervnachrichten so work related nervkram schreibst du so abends und dann war ich nämlich in furiosa komme aus dem kino raus wir alle kennen den moment du machst das Handy wieder an und hast so nervige Nachrichten und da waren so auf verschiedenen Medien Slack, Whatsapp, war von dir so kack Nachfragen, von Antworten, die du kennst. Stefan, wir müssen den Podcast lauter machen, es muss lauter sein, die Leute beschweren sich, es ist zu leise.
Wir müssen mehr Erfolgen machen, wir müssen mehr Geld verdienen. Es kam so nerviger Shit, so viel zu spät, das war irgendwie so 23.30 Uhr, irgendwie, und da wollte ich noch sagen, nein, man kann bei Slack, habe ich aber auch jetzt erst erfahren, weil ich auch immer so bin, wenn man halt gerade dran ist, schreibe ich was und denke mir so, liegt in der Verantwortung des Rezipienten, wann er das liest und wie er es liest. Sehr gut, wichtiger Satz, merken? Denke ich mir nämlich nicht, jetzt inzwischen mehr. Gut, unwichtiger Satz, streichen.
Und ich denke mir, nee, du bist verantwortlich für die schlechte Dauer im Zweifel. Anderer, weil du kannst inzwischen, geht es nicht mehr, es ist so eine 2000er Einstellung, dass du dein Handy ausmachst, dein Arbeitshandy wahrscheinlich noch, und dann kriegst du keine Nachrichten mehr und du kannst sozusagen die Welt ausbinden. Nein, geht nicht mehr. Wir haben alles auf einem Handy, wir haben Slack auf dem Handy, wir haben Mails auf dem Handy, das sind private vermischen mit Business Mails und du nervst mich mit deinem Arbeitsnervkram, wenn du deine Sinne dreissig das schreibst. Und deswegen finde ich, man kann bei Slack zum Beispiel, und das sollte man bei WhatsApp auch einführen, kann man Nachrichten schedule. Das zieht es am nächsten Tag um zehn. Das finde finde ich dann super schwierig, weil was ist, wenn ich in der Nacht sterbe?
Und dann kriegst du quasi Nachricht aus dem Grab.
Das ist mal ein geiles Alibi.
Und du denkst dir, fuck, was ist passiert hier? Das ist mal ein geiles Alibi.
Ich finde, das ist einfach zu gruselig.
Obwohl Florentin ist verstorben und alle trauern.
Und da kommt um elf Uhr so eine nervige...
So, Dinge, die bei uns gerade nicht funktionieren.
Stefan, wir müssen mal gucken, weil wir haben Echo auf der Folge, das funktioniert überhaupt nicht, ich muss das immer irgendwie rausrechnen, das funktioniert nicht.
Und bitte sagt mir vorher Bescheid, welche Clips hier hochladen.
So während der Beerdigung, er war ein gütiger, herzlicher und alle, die gesamte Trauergemeinde.
Oh Gott, this guy, Kotz, ich brauche noch mal alle Fotos von dir für die Website. Uuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhu nicht darauf eingehen, du willst keine Entschuldigungen äußern oder sowas, wie dieses Thema damit abgehakt. Ich sehe mich da nicht in der Verantwortung. Ich habe aber selber immer die
Überlegung, ah, es ist drei Uhr vierzig, wie wirke
ich, wenn ich jetzt so was schreibe.
Das heißt, du machst es nicht mal impulsiv, sondern denkst
darüber nach, dass es vielleicht nicht cool sein könnte
und haust dann trotzdem auf den Senden-Button.
Ja, aber ich denke immer, Stefan, so dreiundzwanzig
vierzig ist bei dir zehn Uhr morgens, du bist
ein Party-Animal, du gehst um die...
Bei mir, dreiundzwanzig vierzig ist bei mir
zehn Uhr morgens. Ja, ich finde, jeder Mensch braucht eine eigene... Weil ich in Singapur lebe. Jeder Mensch hat eine eigene Timezone. Und ich finde, jeder Mensch, zum Beispiel jetzt Social Media, kann ja in seinem Profil schreiben, meine Timezone plus fünf. Das heißt, was für den Normalo, Peter Normalinger, die zwölfe ist, ist für mich elf oder neun. Für mich ist zwölf früh. Wenn du, wenn du auf die Uhr schaust, zwölf, denk acht. Oh, scheiss, wenn du mir was mit Uhrzeit erklärst, ich hab so ein Uhrzeitenproblem, ich kann die Uhr so schlecht lesen, gibt's dir eine Uhr? Naja, jeder Mensch, also ich glaub einfach, dass wenn du sagst, für mich, ich will einfach vor fünfzehn Uhr nicht gestört werden, dann sag ich, meine Timezone ist einfach das jeweilige, so dass alle rechnen können, es ist 12, also ist es für ihn wie sieben morgens. Warum wird die Folge gerade wie Matrix 4? Sieben will ich nicht gestört werden. Ich sag einfach kommuniziert mit den Leuten, was eure Timezone ist.
So, und meine Timezone ist minus acht.
Bin ganz spät unterwegs.
Also drei Uhr nachts.
Ja, hör auf, es mit Uhrzeiten zu erklären.
Es macht sich anschaulicher.
Sag, es ist spät nur früh für dich.
Also, Michael schreibt um neun Uhr vierzig, was für ihn wahrscheinlich so dreizehn Uhr dreissig ist oder sowas. Das ist nicht albern, das jetzt aufzustellen. So, Michael schreibt. Ja. Betreff. Yes. Und der Bußgeldbescheid kam doch. Ist er Betreff? Ist er Betreff. Was ist denn, welcher Titel ist das denn? Ich liebe den Titel. Ja, und der Bußgeldbescheid kam doch.
Das ist doch richtig, man geht mit der Stimme nach unten am Ende. Und der Bußgeldbescheid kam doch.
Guter Titel.
Diese E-Mail hat keinen Inhalt.
Nee, das ist ein MacBook-Problem. Das ist ein MacBook-Problem. Kein Inhalt.
Nein, Florentin, was ist für eine Scheisse jetzt? Das ist der antikiklimatische Moment meines Lebens. Hä? Diese E-Mail hat keinen Inhalt. Michael hat die, also sozusagen die Flaschenpost, das Etikett der Flaschenpost genutzt. Er hat seine Nachricht auf das Etikett der Flaschenpost geschrieben, nicht in den Zettel. Weißt du was, ich habe das Problem mit mir auch manchmal, bei iCloud-Mail. Und dann guck ich auf dem Handy und er hat die Mail-Inhalt. Und ich denk mir so, Macbook. Und das Macbook so ... Nee, er hat keinen Inhalt. Scheiße. Das heißt, Michael scheint ein Mensch zu sein, der auch nur über den Betreff kommuniziert und einfach nichts drin. Der schreibt den kompletten Brief aussen auf den Umschlag und innen ist ein leeres Blatt Papier. The medium is the message. Ja, genau. So kommuniziert Michael. Michael ist so next level, dass er sozusagen dadurch, dass er keine Nachricht sendet, die eigentliche Nachricht sendet. Er sagt alles. Und dafür dafür ist michael bekannt mit wenigen worten sagt er alles was wichtig ist diese e-mail hat keinen inhalt und ich sage die e-mail hat eine menge menge inhalt deswegen meine ich wenn man nichts macht ist es manchmal mehr als was. Genau. Was ist überhaupt eben.
Und das ist es wieder. Nichts ist mehr als was. Diese Mail hat keinen Inhalt. Von Michael ist mehr, sagt im Prinzip mehr als alles, was er vorher geschrieben hat. Das ist, wie wenn du ein komplettes Buch auf den Buchdeckel hinten reinschreibst und die Buchseiten sind alle leer. Das ist einfach ein kompletter Curveball, aber finde ich richtig gut. Wir schreiben ja auch manchmal richtig witzige Texte in irgendwie die Interpretcode der Podcast-Folge oder so, was man dann bei iTunes sehen kann. Da sind die versteckten Dinge. Das wäre doch mal geil. Selbsthilfebuch. Und zwar kann man das, es ist ein leeres Buch, komplett leer. Hinten drauf steht so Klappentexte von Prominenten, also so Rezensionen von Prominenten, so, das ist die wundervollste Biografie, die ich jemals gelesen habe, ein so aufregendes Leben, diese Person ist, dem muss man das Glück der Welt wünschen, das Buch ist komplett leer, vorne drauf ist ein Spiegel und man kann oben eintragen, wen man das schenkt, Zum Beispiel, ich schreibe dann den Florentin Will und klebe dann vielleicht ein Bild von dir auf den Spiegel oder ich zeige es dir ins Gesicht. Moment mal, du klebst ein Bild von mir auf den Spiegel? Diese Spiegelidee kam zu früh. Gut, ich kann es dir auch in die Fresse halten, im Spiegel, dann siehst du dich so starrend. Mein enttäuschter Blick, weil ich mir ein gutes Buch erwartet habe.
Oben habe ich Handschriftlichen geschrieben, Florentin Will, darunter steht eine Biografie und das ganze Buch ist leer, kannst du selber reinschreiben, ein Tagebuch und hinten drauf schreiben Prominente, wow, was ist das für ein tolles Leben und der Bußgeld Bescheid kam, doch. Okay, alles klar.
Das heisst, ich schreibe das Buch dann selber und schreibe es dann selber. Ähm, und der Bußgeldbescheid kam doch. Doch. Okay, alles klar.
Das heisst, ich schreibe das Buch dann selber und schreibe dann rein.
War heute beim Bäcker.
Genau.
Die hatten nicht das Brötchen, was ich gerne mochte, also habe ich ein anderes genommen.
Ja.
Und das haben die dann geschnitten.
Warum musst du das ins Teilbuch schreiben?
War zu dünn geschnitten, aber ich habe mal wieder nichts gesagt.
So ein Lektorvater.
Mal wieder nichts gesagt.
So ein Lektorvater, der ihn so fragt, mein Junge, warum musst du das jetzt genau in dein Tagebuch schreiben?
Also verarbeitest du damit was? Weil es ist ja relativ trivial und uninteressant.
Naja, die Scheiben waren, naja, aber guck mal, schau mal, Papa, was hier hinten auf dem Buchdeckel steht.
Aber das schlägt das Stil. Stephen Hawkins. Stephen Hawkins hat gesagt, das ist die grösste Entdeckung meines Lebens. Und der Mann hat ein schwarzes Loch entdeckt. Okay? Ja. Nur weil du Lektor bist. Hat er nicht, er hat die Hawkins-Strahlung entdeckt. Nicht genau bleiben. Lies mal vor, was Barbara Schöneberger geschrieben hat.
Neben Stephen Hawking, direkt neben Stephen Hawking.
Jeppi, jeppi, jeppi, jeppi, jeppi, jeppi, jeppi, jeppi, krawal und remi, demmi, ganz tolles Buch.
Ganz genau.
Leerzeichen, Ausrufezeichen.
Ja, warum machen das Menschen? Ich kann so schnell, das, das wäre meine Wette bei Wetten dalaus, ich kann so schnell, wenn zwei Leerzeichen drin sind zwischen zwei Wörtern. Oh, das finde ich gut. Das finde ich schön. Ganz schnell entdecken. Das finde ich richtig gut, dass du also einen kompletten Fließtext hast und du zeigst dann genau drauf, wo sind die Doppellehrzeichen. Das geht so. So schnell? Ja, wenn du so eine Seite voll hast. Ich will so eine komplette Wand, wie in so einem Museum, so eine riesige Wand mit so einem Text. Du musst gar nicht hinführen. Aber wo sind deine Augen? Du zeigst mit beiden Fingern. Nee, Peripheriseren reicht. Da habe ich so diese Minority Report. Das ist natürlich jetzt für die Dramaturgie der Sendung nicht gut, wenn es unter eine Sekunde dauert. Stefan Dieter wird er, dass er in unter einer halben Sekunde alle zehn versteckten Lücken findet. Das ist ja mein Problem auch mit Geogassing. Dass es zu schnell ist. Das ist zu gut. Also ich finde, Curb It, alle müssen mal ein bisschen runterkommen mit ihren Skills. Und ich will doch eher, ich weiss ich weiß nicht skills sehen wo ich anknüpfen kann und denke gut der läuft viel schneller als ich wenn ich so richtig sprinte bin ich auch nicht so langsam wenn jemand aber zu gut ist dann wie bei geogassing dann verliert es für mich an reiz weil dann denke ich mir könnte ich auch wenn ich auswendig auswendig lernen könnte ein führables gedächtnis habe ja ja ja ich Ich verstehe schon, aber da, ich mir, könnte ich auch, wenn ich auswendig auswendig lernen könnte und ein führerisches Gedächtnis habe. Ja, ja. Ja, ich verstehe schon. Aber da, ich meine, da muss doch auch mal eine Leiche gefunden werden oder irgendwas. Bei Geoguessern? Ja, das ist mal so das große Event. Geoguessern wird riesengross, nachdem da mal eine Leiche entdeckt wurde, nachdem da mal irgendwie so jemand, der verschwunden ist, entdeckt wurde oder irgendwie sowas. Wenn da wirklich jemand alles sieht, da muss da mal was auftauchen, man muss da mal irgendwas gefunden haben. Und ich meine jetzt nicht irgendwie ein Hund, der eine Rutsche runterfällt oder irgendwie sowas. So gibt es ja wahrscheinlich auch einen Instagram-Account. Hahaha, the funny side of Geoguessing oder sowas. Again, a dog on a Rutsche. A dog on a slide und dann schreiben die Leute, I don't go to Geoguessler if i wanted to laugh i don't go to geogessing in order to laugh laughter is the self-fulfillment of the humans it's demise the way into hell it's my way, was mir aufgefallen ist? Wenn man einmal in der WhatsApp-Gruppe drin ist, ist man da drin. Du kannst nicht, und das ist wirklich, man fragt sich hier gerade, was ändert sich eigentlich wirklich? Ich bin immer so genervt von so Leuten, die sagen, die Jugend kommuniziert nur noch mit dem Handy und so, das kann nicht gut sein. Was ist grossartig anders, außerer dass man schneller ist und effizienter kommunizieren kann und so. Aber man kann aus jedem verkackten Raum einfach mal rausgehen, ohne sozial komplett Selbstmord zu begehen. Aber du kannst nicht aus einer WhatsApp-Gruppe austreten, weil dann immer ganz gross steht, Stefan ist ausgetreten, Stefan hat die Gruppe verlassen. Ja, ja. Die einzige Chance, WhatsApp-Gruppen zu beenden, ist, sie aushungern zu lassen. Aber selbst dann ist es Assi als Erster auszutreten. Ja, nee, du kannst nicht austreten. Es gibt kein Austreten. Die einzige Chance ist, es wirklich aushungern zu lassen. Und dann archivieren oder so. Aggressiv nicht mehr zu schreiben, wenn jemand sagt, hey Leute, alles Gute, Paul. Wirklich aggressiv gelesen, gelesen, gelesen, gelesen, gelesen, starren, stille, wegstarren, nichts, einfach aggressiv nichts machen. Und dann gibt es noch diesen einen, dieses eine Flackern, dieser eine Rüdiger, der versucht, es noch am Leben zu halten, der immer wieder einmal im Jahr schreibt, alles Gute und so und wirklich gelesen, gelesen, gelesen, gelesen, gelesen, aber niemand reagiert. Dann gibt es ja soziale so Monster, die dann so was schreiben wie, ah die Gruppe können wir mal langsam löschen oder passiert ja nicht mehr so viel drin. Das ist schon krass, aber das würde ich niemals machen. Ich bin, ich versauere dann in diesen Gruppen und ich finde es nicht mal, ich meine, das klingt so aggressiv, Stefan hat die Gruppe verlassen, klingt so aggressiv, es ist so schlimm, es ist gar nicht unbedingt so gemeint, es ist einfach so, es betrifft mich nicht mehr, ich bin nicht mehr da vor Ort, wo diese Gruppe ist, ich bin in dem Verein nicht mehr, ich wohne in einer anderen Stadt inzwischen, ich kann nicht mehr mit euch mich abends treffen. Es gibt tausend Arten, einen Raum physisch zu verlassen. Es gibt wirklich den, ähm, ah, ich glaube, ich muss, ah, jetzt, ähm, dann will ich.
Und die ganze Kirche dreht sich um und fragt sich, was redet der Mann da hin, was murmelt der Mann da hin. Oder es gibt natürlich den, okay, so redet ihr nicht mit mir, Tür auf, hinter Tür schlagen. Es gibt hundert Möglichkeiten daraus zu. Genau, aber jeder WhatsApp-Gruppenverlasser wirkt so. Ja, genau. Wirkt wie letzteres wahnsinnig aggressiv und feindlich. Und das ist so schlimm. Vielleicht sollte es unterschiedliche Optionen geben. Ah, ich habe gesehen, Sie möchten die WhatsApp-Gruppe verlassen. Auf welche Art? Und dann haben Sie verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Stefan stürmt aus der WhatsApp-Gruppe. Und knallt die Tür. Und knallt die Tür. Stefan schleicht sich unbemerkt aus der WhatsApp-Gruppe. Stefan hat leider, leider, leider, leider noch einen dringenden Termin und muss los. Ah, Stefan ist aus Versehen auf Gruppe verlassen gekommen. Stefan dachte, es sei die Toilette und ist zur Tür rausgegangen. So was. Und bei Clubhouse, wo viele dachten, es wird der neue Heise Scheiss, war es nicht, ist auch nichts übergeblieben. Aber was ich mir gewünscht hätte, was von Club aus überbleibt, ist der Leave Quietly Button. Der hieß sogar so, leave quietly. Mehr will ich nicht, leave quietly. Und dann einfach nur, es kommt keine Nachricht, nichts, tschüss, weg. Und dann irgendwann so, Stefan ist gleich mit einer Gruppe drin. Ja, ja. Das Schlimmste ist ja Instagram Live, wo du so live streamen kannst und die Leute es anscheinend sofort merken, riesengroß, ah, Florentin ist jetzt auch mit dabei, und dann so, ah, hello, hello guy, und du einfach sofort raus, einfach viel, gesamter Raum schaut dich an, viel zu viel Aufmerksamkeit auf dir drauf und dann sofort wieder raus. Furchtbar, du musst einfach still durch die Fensterscheibe gucken können, immer, egal was es ist.
Ja, und da finde ich sollte sich, weil das sind ja mal die grossen Unternehmen, die uns diktieren, wie unsere sozialen Gefüge sind gerade und so.
Wir haben nicht so viel Auswahl. Wir haben diese fünf Messenger oder vier, mit denen wir arbeiten können, nur weil die alle benutzen. Und ich finde, die haben die Verantwortung, uns so eine Möglichkeit zu geben. Eine Leave Quietly Funktion. Ihr baut die komplette Kultur. Genau. So, und man muss es einfach zurücklassen. Ich denke immer an deine verlorene Stadt, verfluchte Stadt, die dem Dschungel überlassen wurde. A la cero verpedida. So sehe ich auch eine WhatsApp-Gruppe. So dieses, wir verlassen sie, wir lassen sie zurück, wir gehen weg, wir ziehen weiter, aber sie wächst da in ihrem Dschungel vor sich hin. Ja. Und ab und zu blubbert da vielleicht nochmal, wacht da jemand auf oder so, der vergessen wurde, aber ansonsten haben wir damit nichts mehr zu tun. Nee, genau, genau. Ich will damit nichts zu tun haben. Ich will damit gar nichts zu tun haben. Weg. Weg, es war ein Fehler. Es war ein Fehler. Ja, ich habe die Gruppe Tiramisu Lava, habe ich damals wirklich mit Venen fahren betreten. L-U-V-V-A.
Okay. Ach so, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Ist das Italienisch?
Stefan hat die Gruppe verlassen. Stefan hat das Gespräch verlassen.
Während er schreibt. So, erst mal Stefan ist typing, Stefan ist typing, Stefan ist typing, Stefan ist left the conversation.
Ich will, er sagt so viel aus. Er hat sich zu oft verschrieben, wütend, Selbsthass, was auch immer.
Stefan ist Typing, Stopp, nichts mehr, nichts mehr.
Stefan ist Typing, Typing, Typing, Gruppe verlassen.
Das ist ja auch so ein Phänomen, das man wahrscheinlich vor drei Jahren oder vor zehn Jahren nicht kannte, in zehn Jahren auch nicht mehr kannte.
Dieses Fussgängerzone, ah, links, rechts, links, rechts und das im WhatsApp-Chat. Stefan ist ist typing, ah, dann höre ich aufzuschreiben. Ja, ja, ja. Dann höre ich aufzuschreiben. Fange ich anzuschreiben, Stefan will anzuschreiben. Und das ist wirklich hin und her, bis man einfach gar nichts sagt. Man kann sich ja auch unterbrechen. Das mache ich manchmal, weil ich den Absatz, den Umbruch als rhetorisches Mittel nutze. Du lässt die Unterbrechung, du lässt Raum für die Unterbrechung. Ich lasse, genau, nicht bewusst, weil ich das, aber dann unterbricht mich jemand, weil der auch was schreibt und dann denke ich so, oh jetzt toll, alles zerstört. Und das ist ja auch spannend, neuerdings kann man ja Nachrichten bearbeiten. Das ist ja, bei WhatsApp zumindest, kann man ja jetzt inzwischen in die Nachricht reingehen und sie komplett bearbeiten. Sie muss zwangsläufig nichts mehr damit zu tun haben, was vorher da stand. Das ist der Untergang der Kultur.
Falls Sie so ein paar Fragen, wann war diese Kultur, wann war der Kipppunkt, würde ich sagen, das ist der Kipppunkt.
Glaube ich auch.
Weil das ist die digitale, das digitale Vertrauen ist komplett kaputt.
Nee, und dann eine super spannende Entscheidung, vor der man dann stand, als die Entscheider, als die da oben, war, wenn du dann Bezug nimmst auf eine Nachricht, man kann direkt antworten, was steht denn da drin? Die bearbeitete Nachricht oder die unbearbeitete Nachricht? Oder das Original, ja. Und die Antwort ist das, was zum Zeitpunkt der Antwort da drin stand, was natürlich genial ist. Okay, das ist gut. Das heisst, wenn du sicher gehen willst, dass der nicht mehr das ändern will, ändern kann, musst du darauf antworten und dann den Nagel reinhauen und das dann drin haben. Aber Nachrichten korrigieren ist auch immer so ein bisschen, weil ich schreibe oft einfach wild und dann denke ich mir, schreibt man das wirklich so? Und dann so, ja, ich glaube, wir sollten das dann mal irgendwie im Voraus planen. Wie viele R hat Voraus? Drei. Wie viele R sind drei? Nach der neuen Rechtsprechung, es kommt nur eins dazu. Und dann hätte ich mir so, jetzt entweder sofort korrigieren oder warten, bis die andere Person und dann gucken. Weil was ich nicht will, ist die Person liest es und während sie liest, einfach ändert sich das Voraus von einem R zu drei und die Person denkt, ah, diese Konversation ist dir anscheinend so, ist es dir so wichtig, dass ich denke, dass du korrekt schreibst, dass du das extra nochmal gegoogelt hast und extra nochmal korrigiert hast.
Lustig, weil damals, wenn man eine Nachricht falsch, man hat einen Crush. Man will nur schreiben und sehr aufregend alles. Das ist so eine Nachricht, wo man das Handy umdreht, wenn man sie abgesteckt hat. So eine Nachricht. Und dann verschreibt man sich. Und früher war so, fuck, selbsthaft, warum gibt es keine Bearbeiten-Funktionen. Aber jetzt bearbeitet man das, dann steht unter und drunter bearbeitet. Man hat ja jetzt die Möglichkeit auch, es unbearbeitet und dadurch nonchalant wirkend zu lassen wie es ist ja aber dadurch
sagst du natürlich auch was aus also du sagst natürlich auch aus wenn ein wort offensichtlich offensichtlich auto der autokorrektur fluch zum opfer gefallen also vielleicht können wir dann morgen abend banane und dann denkst du dir okay wenn das jetzt nicht korrigiert wird wie wie Wie unwichtig bin ich der Person?
Baby handeln, belassen, was könnte es... okay, wenn das jetzt nicht korrigiert wird, wie unwichtig bin ich der Person?
Behandeln, belassen, was kann das bedeuten? Unklar. Ja, das ist kein Versprecher, den ich damit meine. Es wäre eher so dieses Nicht, wo ein X reingerutscht ist noch. Okay, also du möchtest seriöser wirken und nichts mit CH schreiben, anstatt nix. Ne, ne, ich meine, wenn man manchmal schreibt, hier an der Laptop-Tastatur zum Beispiel, da ist das x ja neben dem c. Und manchmal passiert es mir, dass ich nicht mit x h schreibe. Nicht. Also eine Mischung aus nix und nix. Das ist ja nochmal komplett was Neues. Ich kann auch schlecht sagen, aber da mit einem X drin. Das ist ja spannend. Das finde ich interessant. Weil das sei dann, der, der, das Gegenüber weiss ja nicht, wolltest du nix mit X schreiben? Nee, dann hättest du kein H geschrieben, ne? Und das T dahinter wäre auch nicht drin. Jetzt habe ich eine komplette Doktorarbeit, jetzt habe ich die Datei aufgemacht. Wollte eine Doktorarbeit über die linguistischen Feinheiten der digitalen Kommunikation schreiben. Und Stefan titzelt und kommt und reisst mit dem Teppich gewaltsam unter den Füssen davon und ich fall auf dem Boden wie ein Käfer. Ich stehe so schnell nicht mehr auf. Ich habe, das ist, apropos Teppich, ich habe so ein bisschen ausgemistet bei mir und ein alter Teppich hat mir nicht mehr gefallen. Okay. Und der war recht teuer damals. Der war recht teuer. Und dann habe ich den, und der war so teuer auch, weil er eine spezielle Masse hatte, die ich brauchte. Gab da nicht so viele. So wie so ein Halbmond erst? Ne, die Masse waren so 253 x 186, so wie. Ach so, okay. Und dann habe ich den bei Ebay reingemacht, Kleinanzeigen erst, und dachte mir, ja, irgendwer wird den schon kaufen für den Originalpreis. Passt schon? Nein, nein, nein. Und da war der jetzt ein halbes Jahr drin. Das alte Porzellanteller-Problem, wo du sie am Ende wegwirst. Aber das passiert mir nicht nochmal. Und deswegen habe ich den jetzt mit einer Auktion bei normalen eBay reingestellt. Da, wow! So, und weißt du, bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen war der am Ende noch bei 300 Euro oder 200 Euro oder sowas. Hat niemand gekauft dafür. Und auch bei Ebay habe ich dann so Mindestgebot 100 reingemacht und dachte mir, irgendwer wird der wohl 100 bieten, das ist ein super guter Preis. Auch nicht passiert, da wurde immer wieder neu eingestellt. Irgendwann habe ich riskiere es startgebot ist ein euro nachdem wir dann werden darauf bieten dann wird man sehen es ist eine nachfrage da der bedarf ist da leute schaukeln sich hoch und merken dann manchmal braucht man auch so ein bisschen den schwarm der etwas sich für etwas interessiert um zu merken es ist in der tat spannend spannend und auch bezahlwert. Und nein, ich habe den jetzt für zwei Euro einundfünfzig. Wie die Summe zustande gekommen ist, frage ich mich auch. Das heißt aber, jemand hat zwei Euro fünfzig geboten, jemand hat gesagt, so nicht mit mir, zwei einundfünfzig. Zwei einundfünfzig. Und du hast noch nicht mal die Abstände eingestellt, dass man nicht in einem Set Abständen bieten darf. Kann man das? Das ist, glaube ich, der klassische Fehler, ist, dass die sich mit einem Cent dann hochsteigern und dann arbeitest du nicht über Wochen von 1,80 auf 2,60 hoch, weil dann hunderte Gebote da irgendwie in ein Set Abständen hochgehen. Ich glaube, dass richtig viele Fehler passiert. Ja, dass richtig viele Fehler passiert. Diesen Abstand habe ich nicht gewusst. Dann habe ich gesehen, es gibt auch einen Mindestwert, den kann man einstellen, nicht der Startwert, das Startgebot, das ist das einzige, was ich kannte, sondern einen Mindestwert, den man erreichen muss. Wenn der nicht erreicht wird, wird es nicht verkauft. Ja, das ist aber, das geht nicht. Das finde ich auch geht nicht. Bei einer Auktion musst du all in gehen, das ist die Idee der Auktion. Kannst du nicht die ganze Zeit mega mit Elan sagen, na, 50 Euro wenn du sagen wurde nicht verkauft nicht verkauft der eigentliche preis sollte 10.000 euro sein ja genau schade ja cool dann haben wir jetzt umsonst hier unsere schilder gehoben für die letzte halbe stunde lächerlich und meine ich habe die 13 so aufgehoben ja lächerlich leute ja und jetzt habe ich den für zwei euro 51 Und jetzt kommen so Gedanken rein, wie ich behaupte, er wurde gegrache, Selbsthass, Ebay-Hass, der Gedanke, was kann man vielleicht machen jetzt, behaupten, er wurde geklaut in der Zwischenzeit. Wie realistisch ist es, dass jemand einen Teppich klaut? Dann hat auch ein Freund von mir vorgeschlagen, hey, behaupte doch einfach, ah, du merkst gerade, der war schon ein bisschen älter, lag ein bisschen rum und jetzt wurde noch mal heraus, hervorholst zum Verkaufen. Ja. Du merkst, ah, ist kaputt gegangen. Ja, ja, Spinneneier, Motteneier. Genau. Ich glaube aber, der wurde so günstig verkauft, dass man selbst bei sowas noch sagen würde, ja, kann wohl nicht ab. Ja, ja. Ach so, ja gut, er hat so ein riesen Brandfleck, ne? Du, ehrlich gesagt, pff, 2,51 Euro, komm, auch mit Brandflecken nehme ich den. Ja, aber ich habe da auch mal irgendwie so dann mit Essig einladen gemacht, von Kohlen ist mir Essig da drüber und jetzt ätzt es da so ein riesen Loch rein. Hey, kein Problem, gar kein Problem, irgendwie, es ist immer noch, selbst wenn man den in die Hälfte durchschneidet, ist er noch sehr viel weniger Arbeiten bezahlt, als er wert ist. Ja ja, da sind alle Haare weg und da ist wirklich nur noch wie so ein trauriger Lappen einfach und selbst den habe ich im Kofferraum gehabt die ganze Woche.
Ja, aber zwei Euro und einundfünfzig riesen Lappen ist auch geil, also da kann man ihn klein schneiden für Küchentücher oder so.
Ja, er ist weg, er ist weg.
Ah, okay, ja dann selbst das, ich gebe ihm lieber zwei Euro und fünfzig. Lappen ist auch geil, also da kann man den Kleinschneiden für Küchentücher oder so. Er ist weg, er ist weg.
Ah, okay. Ja, dann selbst das, ich gebe Ihnen lieber 2,51 Euro, um Sie glücklich zu sehen.
Ja, ich habe mir mehr erwartet, Einkaufspreis 4.000 Euro, aber gut, ist angekommen, angekommen.
Das ist jetzt wirklich doof.
Und jetzt musst du den irgendwie verschicken oder irgendwie verrühren?
Nee, da habe ich zumindest clever den Haken gesetzt bei Nur Abholung. Aber jetzt, ich dachte ja, ich bin schlau, gehe aus dieser Porzellansache clever heraus. Ich finde, jetzt bin ich noch schlechter unterm Strich weggekommen, weil das war ja irgendwie noch so ein befreiendes Element. Dieses Wegwerfen. Und dann steht man da mit diesem Porzellan. das hat was wie so ein Ende von so einem Indie-Film.
Ja, wenn du einen Teppich ins Meer wirfst, das wirkt natürlich auch verdächtig, ne, also das ist natürlich die klassische Mafia, ich hab hier eine Leiche loszuwerden Situation, aber ich bin da auch verkaufen, ich weiß, das hört man nicht gerne, aber ich mag so, ich mag wiederverwerten, mag ich nicht, mich nervt es, ich mag auch Essensreste nicht, so wenn du irgendwie im Büro bist, im Kühlschrank. Deine eigene oder andere? Ich lasse nichts übrig, ich esse alles auf und andere Essensreste, ich verfolge das immer so, Kollegen essen dann was und dann hast du da irgendwie noch so eine Tupperdose Nudeln im Kühlschrank. Aha, dann gucke ich mir die an, nächster Tag, übernächster Tag, Woche später, immer noch da. Ich denke mir, das wird nichts mehr. Trotzdem sind sie noch da. Und ich will wirklich manchmal das Experiment machen, Essensreste sofort wegzuschmeissen, um zu merken, ach, ihr vermisst die ja gar nicht. Ihr wolltet die ja gar nicht mehr essen. Niemand will am nächsten Tag noch scheiß Essensreste. Ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß. Ich hab's oft genug erlebt, dass es dann ewig rumliegt und irgendwie alles dann voll stinkt und irgendwie dann so ein halber Wurstsalat dann noch da rumliegt. Es gibt auch nichts widerlicheres als Gemeinschaftskühlschränke. Ruchbar, ruchbar. Die sind immer widerlich. Aber ich glaube, ich bin auch ein Kollegen Arschloch. So, ich habe, ich glaube, ich habe. Wann ist es aufgefallen, als du dann abends um 0.30 fiese Mails schreibst oder...
Nee, ich sage es, ich sage es genau, ich habe, es gab eine neue Kollegin in der Firma und dann schreibt man ja manchmal so, ah, okay, die ist jetzt dabei und so, aber hat sie ja noch nicht persönlich getroffen. Und dann ist natürlich immer die Frage so, wie wird der erste Eindruck aussehen, so fragt man sich, ah, okay, wie ist das dann so. Und du reingst, Ansch Anschiss. Und dann war ich nochmal in der Firma hier unterwegs, sehr spät, und ich dachte, ich bin allein in der Firma. Ich dachte nicht, dass noch jemand da ist. Und dann verhält man sich ja auch mal anders, eher so wie zu Hause, sag ich mal. Du hast laut gefurzt. Man verhält sich ja auch mal eher wie zu Hause, wenn man auch in öffentlichen Räumen, wenn man sich sicher ist, ich bin alleine, niemand ist mehr da, irgendwie, ich schliesse ab oder so, ich hole mir noch kurz ein Glas Wasser, nehme meine Sachen, gehe nach Hause und dann bin ich durch den Korridor gelaufen und habe meinen Bauch gekratzt. Oh, hast du das Shirt hochgenommen? Ja. Shirt hochgenommen, Bauch gekratzt. Ich habe das Shirt hochgenommen und meinen Bauch gekratzt. Wie hoch war das Shirt? Über Bauchnabel oder Unterbauchnabel? Ich würde sagen, es war auf Bauchnabelhöhe. Bauchnabelhöhe, okay. Und ich habe meinen Bauch einfach wirklich meinen Schwarz. Wie so, so selig? Oder war es so ein wenig zweimal? Nee, es war schon, also es war in der Bewegung natürlich, aber es war glaube ich schon ein ausgelassenes Bauchkatzen. Also wirklich jetzt kein so ein schnell, sondern ein Balou der Bär. Genau, wie so eine Katze, die auf dem Sofa liegt und einfach mal sich kratzt und einfach mal alles rauslässt und sich wirklich auch einen Selbstwellnesstag gönnt. Und dann biege ich Bauchkratzen um die Ecke und dann sitzt die Kollegin da und schaut mich an.
Und den Bauch?
Der Bauch war im Raum. Der Bauch war auch im Raum.
Und ich höre natürlich sofort auf, ah hi, ah okay und sie sagt aber gar nichts mehr.
Und ich sage mir okay und dann ...
Sie hat nichts dazu gesagt?
Nee, nichts dazu gesagt, generell nichts gesagt.
Dann gehe ich noch kurz in die Küche, gehe zurück, auf Weg zurück aus der Küche, sie ist weg. Arbeitet sie noch da? Ja, aber das war's. Ich habe sie ja demnächst nicht mehr getroffen. Scheisse! Für dich als Menschenkenner, also ist es ... Nee, ist nicht so schlimm. Ist nicht so schlimm. Deswegen habe ich gefragt, wie hoch war das Shirt?
Also wenn das jetzt so hoch ...
Das ist ja eine normale Sache.
Wenn man sich sicher wägt ...
Ja, ich weiss natürlich nicht, wie es aus ihrer Perspektive wird.
Also ist es natürlich immer was anderes.
Genau, sie hatte die Froschperspektive.
Mehr Bauch.
Voluminöser Bauch, gekratzt, wallend.
Wallend.
Ich weiss nicht, wo das jetzt auf der unangenehmen Skala der Bauch ...
Die Mehr Bauch. Voluminöser Bauch, gekratzt, wallend. Wallend. Ich weiß nicht, wo das jetzt auf der unangenehmen Skala der Bauch ... Ist ja auch unterschiedlich bei Menschen, welche Körperteile man eher eklig findet. Manche sind irgendwie bis barfuß super eklig, aber dafür bauchfrei kein Problem, für andere andersrum, keine Ahnung. Ja, ja. Deswegen ... Nee, ich finde, du bist da fein. Also das finde ich völlig okay. Ich finde Bauchnabelhöhe finde ich völlig okay, Bauchkratzen auch, dann die Uhrzeit auch. Ich finde, die Uhrzeit hat einen grossen Einfluss darauf, wie man sich im Büro verhalten kann. Sagen wir, elf Uhr morgens, Bier in der Hand, selbst bei den Rocket Beans, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. wenn du um elf uhr abends noch im büro hast du ein Bier in der Hand bei den Rocket Beans? Selbst in einer, nicht bei den Rocket Beans, selbst in einer anderen, ich weiß nicht, im Work Environment, glaube ich, kein Problem. Abends immer beim Bierchen, ist eher noch, ah, guck, der Mitarbeiter, der trinkt hier mit unseren anderen Mitarbeitern das Bierchen. Ja, ja, ja. Krawatte auf, erster Knopf des Hemds auf. Aber habe ich, glaube ich, erzählt schon mal, aber ich habe neulich mal irgendwann gehört, ein Management-Tipp, wenn man die Karriereleiter hochsteigen will, walk the floors, walk the floors. Geh die Gänge. Genau, wenn du, es kam glaube ich von so einer Nike Executive Geschäftsführerin, bla bla bla, wenn man aufsteigen will, die Karriereleiter, zeig dich. Und ihr Tipp war, walk the floors, gerade in Zeiten von Homeoffice, Zoom-Teams, bla bla bla, geht in die Firma, and walk the floors. Einfach den ganzen Tag durch die Gegend laufen. Wenn man die floors walkt, dann wird man gesehen, man merkt, ah, da kümmert sich jemand um die Leute, den kennen alle. Awareness, wenn man sich überlegt, wen könnte man jetzt in diese Position heben, dann wahrscheinlich die Person, die man gerade sieht, weil sie den Flur entlangläuft. Ja klar. Und jemand, der den Flur entlangläuft, wirkt jemand, der sehr beschäftigt ist. Immer beschäftigt. Also man muss natürlich auch beschäftigt, jetzt nicht bauchkratzend, fläzig die Gänge entlanglaufen. Ich glaube, da habe ich eher falsch... Du hast zwei Sachen richtig gemacht. Okay. Du warst noch lange da. Ja.
Und you walked the... bauchkratzend fläht sich die Gänge entlanglaufen. Ich glaube, da habe ich den eher falsch ... Du hast zwei Sachen richtig gemacht.
Okay.
Du warst noch lange da.
Ja.
Und you walked the floor.
Und jetzt muss ich sagen ...
You scratched the belly.
You scratched the belly, aber you scratched the belly zu einer Uhrzeit, wo man ...
Es ist belly scratch time.
Ah, okay.
Vergiss das Bier nicht.
Ja, okay, verstehe.
Das würde ich auch auf Augenhöhe, also Bauch ist so ...
Also mit dem zweiten Hemdknopf geht auch der Bauch. Irgendwann mal hoch. Hoch, ja. Okay, ich verstehe. Das will ich auch auf Augenhöhe. Also Bauch ist so, also mit dem zweiten Hemdknopf geht auch der Bauch. Irgendwann mal hoch. Hoch, ja. Okay, ich verstehe. Gut. Ja, das ist der klassische Zivitrick, das habe ich auch auf dem Zivildienstlehrgang gelernt. Zivik. Dass wenn man geschäftig wirken will, sich nicht verstecken, das ist schlecht, das ist der erste Reflex, wer faul sein will, versteckt sich. Genau. Im Gegenteil, sei überpräsent. Überpräsent. Überpräsent, nimm dir eine Kiste, trag die von A nach B, trag die von B nach A, bestenfalls zwei Kisten, pack die eine Kiste in die andere, damit es anders aussieht, geh wieder zurück, richtig schwere Kiste, sorry, kann ich kurz durch, kann ich kurz durch, sorry, ich muss wirklich weiter. Und immer so genervt gucken ein bisschen, weil genervt gleich gestresst gleich beschäftigt.
Genau, am Aufzug stehen, immer am Aufzug genervt auf die Treppe gucken.
Ah, soll ich nicht die Treppe nehmen? Aufzug. Ah, Mann, wo bleibt der denn? Ah, Mann, wo bleibt der denn? Ah, Mann, wo bleibt der denn? Ah, Mann, wo bleibt der denn? Ah, und einfach alles geben. Also, wir hatten seit drei Monaten keinen Auftrag mehr, was macht der? Ah, die Kiste muss in den vierten Stock. Wir haben keinen vierten, der Stock ist nicht mehr angemietet. Mann, scheiße, nehme ich jetzt die Feuertreppe, Mensch. Einfach überbeschäftigt wirken, das ist der klassische Trick. Ja, ja, glaube ich auch. Das ist auch immer gut. Das ist, glaube ich, genau. Deswegen, Walk the Floors ist ja in erster Linie nicht produktiv sein. Die Zeit, die man quasi aufbringen müsste, um zu arbeiten, ist man ja damit beschäftigt, sich die Flure lang zu watscheln. Von daher
ist es kein Produktivitätstrip, es ist nur
so ein Trick,
wie du bei den anderen im Kopf was auslöst.
Ich finde es spannend.
Also du sagst, ich bin safe, keine Entschuldigung
nötig. Und ich glaube, es war ein reines
Missverständnis. Keine Merci-Packung
am Arbeitsplatz, um zu sagen,
T-Shirt drüber,
Bauch drüber. Geh zu ihr hin und und sag ich weiss es war unschön aber wir sollten darüber reden es jetzt zu schweigen macht keinen sinn ich soll das gespräch suchen geht es aber auch schon eine weile her also geh jetzt doch mal zu ihr hin und sag aber es jetzt zu schweigenweigen, vor allen Leuten laut, aber es jetzt totzuschweigen macht ja auch keinen Sinn. Kein Hallo, einfach laut für den Satz beginnen, ja. Es wären dann die ersten Wörter zu ihr, ne? Die ersten Worte wären. Es jetzt totzuschweigen ergäbe macht ja auch keinen Sinn. Gut, okay. Also wir üben das mal. Ich stelle mich hinter sie, sitze auf ihrem Stuhl, ich stelle mich direkt hinter sie. Laut, laut? Laut, okay, laut stelle ich mich hinter sie. Es jetzt tot zu schweigen macht auch keinen Sinn. Ja, aber es jetzt tot zu schweigen macht ja auch keinen Sinn. Aber es jetzt tot zu schweigen macht auch keinen Sinn. Okay, gut. Und alle werden denken, hä, was ist zwischen den beiden vorgefallen? Doch, ich glaube, alle werden sich denken ganz klar, was zwischen euch vorgefallen ist. Aber niemand liegt richtig. Ja, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hat sie es auch rum erzählt, überall schon. Ich weiß es nicht. Ja, hast du das Gefühl, es werden dir Sticker aufgeklebt und wird sich der Bauch gekratzt in einer verulbten Art? Ey, ich hab nix gegen guten Bauchkratzer, ohne Witz, ich sag's dir, ich hab, der Bauch ist eh, also immer, immer wenn du zum...
Juckt ja häufiger! Immer wenn du jemanden darstellen willst in so einer Klischee-Comics-Situation, dem es richtig gut geht, der sitzt mit seinem dicken Bauch unterm Baum und kratzt sich den Bauch. Oder reibt sich den Bauch. Ich denke an drei ... Oder hält sich den Bauch. An drei Dinge. Der Bauch ist das Wohlfühlzentrum. Genau, in meinem Kopf kratzen sich den Bauch. Homer Simpson, Patrick Star, Simpson Homer, Star Patrick, Vinnie the Pooh und Pooh the Wing. Vinnie the Pooh hat den perfekten Bauchkratz-Outfit. Sein T-Shirt geht genau bis über den Bauch, die Armlänge ist ideal, der kann sich den Bauch kratzen, so viel er will. Ich würde entgegen gehen mit Patrick Star hat das beste Bauchkratz-Outfit. Stimmt auch, ja. Da kommt es von unten. Wunderbar, da bist du einfach bereit. Da ist dir nichts dagegen. Griffin Peter? Ja, Griffin, Peter, ja, finde ich auch gut. Buddha, auch Buddha so, da sitzen, einfach so, ja, mal am Bauch kratzen. Hast du gegrinst, hast du eine Melodie gepfiffen? Ich hatte, ich glaube, wahrscheinlich Kopfhörer auf, ich habe meistens Kopfhörer auf, aber ich habe keine Melodie gepfiffen währenddessen. Atmest du komisch, wenn du die Kopfhörer auf hast? Äh, äh, also so halt normal. Okay, weil dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das Ganze doch noch problematischer ankam. Dann solltest du wirklich zu ihr hingehen und sagen, aber es jetzt tot zu schweigen, macht ja auch keinen Sinn. Auch zu laut, weil ich die Kopfhörer noch aufhabe. Genau. Weil jetzt kann ich mir vorstellen, dass du laufschnaufend Bauchkratz in diesen Raum gegangen bist und so ein bisschen, ja, es kann natürlich ein bisschen predatorhaft wirken, muss ich jetzt nochmal drüber nachdenken.
Okay, ja, ich weiss es nicht. Ich weiss auch nicht genau, was ich gerade machen soll.
Vielleicht, falls sich jemand auskennt, falls jemandem das auch schon mal passiert ist,
falls wir Bauchkratzer unter unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern haben.
Doch, es gibt, glaube ich, uns da draußen die ganze Riege an Bauchkratzern.
Doch, doch, wir haben eine Lobby.
Ich glaube, unser Publikum ist nicht, Bauchkratz nicht. Doch, doch, glaub schon. Meinst du? Es gibt da Bauchnabelfreaks da draußen. Und schöne Schwartenkratzer. Schwartenkratzer. Wir sind die schönen Schwartenkratzer. Ich mache jetzt eine WhatsApp-Gruppe auf für alle Schwartenkratzer. Okay, okay. Ich lade dich ein und da kommen einfach... Nee, brauchst du nicht. Doch, klar, ich lade dich ein. Ich lade dich ein. Ich lade dich ein. Ich lade dich ein. Ich lade dich ein. Ich lade dich ein. Ich lade dich ein. Ich mache einfach mit uns beiden die direkt auf.
So, weil ich habe eine Nummer und dann mache ich die einfach direkt mit uns beiden auf und lade dann die Leute ein.
Und dann kann einfach da mal wirklich abgekratzt werden.
Das ist einfach ein Safe Space für Schwartenkratzer, wo alle sich kratzen können, wie sie wollen.
Ja, brauche ich nicht.
Ohne schlechtes Gewissen.
Klar, brauchst du auch mal.
Ja, aber irgendwann dann nicht mehr und dann kann ich nicht wieder raus. Stefan, wir sehen uns nächste Woche. Wenn es wieder heisst, warum bist du aus der WhatsApp-Gruppe ausgetreten, in die ich so viel Arbeit reingesteckt habe? Wollt ihr aus der Pufo-Telegram-Gruppe austreten, dann finde ich, wir geben euch jetzt die Freiwoche, die sozial darf nicht geshamt werden, es ist völlig okay, wenn euch die Gruppe nervt, weil es werden viele Nachrichten geschrieben, mehrere Tausend am Tag. Das ist ja auch so die Idee, finde ich, also ihr habt gar keinen Bock auf Feiertage, nämlich Nervenfeiertage, dass man wirklich sagt, okay, aber WhatsApp stellt für einen Tag den Schalter um, dass es keine Benachrichtigung gibt, wenn man rausgeht. Social Freedom Day. Einfach so der Social Freedom, let me get the fuck out of your day. SFD, Social Freedom Day. So, und dass dann diesen einen Tag alle rausgehen dürfen und danach wird der Knebel wieder angezogen. Super. Und dann muss man halt an dem Tag wirklich reagieren. Würde mich viel mehr reizen als diese dummen Feiertage, wo du vor dem versperrten Edeka stehst und denkst, wo soll ich jetzt irgendwie meine Cherry-Cola herkriegen. Und falls ihr da draußen Florentin Bauch kratzend oberkörperfrei gesehen habt, dann wendet euch an die jetzt hier eingeblendete Nummer. Die Notfallnummer. Das ist die Selbsthilfenummer. Und da trifft sich ein kleiner Kreis. Bislang sind es noch nicht so viele Leute, haben noch nicht so viele Leute gesehen. Drei treffen sich trotzdem in der Lanxess Arena in Köln, haben trotzdem angebietet, weil wir dachten, das sind mehr. Es kam dann nicht so viele. Es gibt irgendeinen sehr reichen Geldgeber da im Hintergrund, unklar wer, aber irgendjemand hat da richtig mal ein paar scheine...
Ich habe bei jemandem nämlich in Verdacht, jemand, der sehr billig Teppiche einkauft und dann für teuer Geld wieder verkauft.
Aber ich will niemanden dafür schämen. Vielen Dank an dich für die Folge, vielen Dank an euch draußen.
Haut rein.
Wir hauen rein auch und heben dann jetzt auch mal ab.
Bis nächste Woche, wir sehen uns wieder.